all right it's friday let's get into
this week's mailbag remember you can
email info
davidpakman.com with your thoughts your
questions your
anything really just know try to reduce
the abuse in the email uh and don't send
10 10 emails a day you'll get yourself
flagged directly into the trash and
we've
sadly there's like 50 people now getting
auto filtered directly into the trash
okay let's start today's first email is
actually not an email it's from twitter
where a user named akbar said
david who does your vetting for your
calls it seems like a large portion is
just trolling you and getting you to
answer questions that are asked in bad
faith pretending to be progressive you
know there are a lot of really fair
critiques of our phone callers um
including that they take five minutes to
get to the question that they call from
really loud places that they don't
really have anything to ask but just
kind of want to rant for a while
there's a lot of really good critiques
i don't think
this critique is accurate that people
are trolling me and asking bad faith
questions i i have never gotten that
impression
um and that they're pretending to be
progressive
if anybody can even point to one
specific such call i
if this is happening it's going
completely over my head
and i should be aware of it so please
let me know if there are specific calls
that that meet that definition because i
haven't seen them here's another message
via facebook
you are a habitual liar
now you know
you can say hey david sometimes you get
things wrong you can say david sometimes
when it's statistics or math
or calculus related elements on the show
you get them wrong or sometimes you get
a fact wrong
but
one of the things i don't do here is lie
to you
or tell you that i believe things that i
don't really believe everything i say on
the program i really believe and i
believe to be true at the time and
sometimes i get things wrong and when i
am aware of it i will apologize i throw
myself at the mercy of the audience and
i issue a correction i will i will do
that a few emails from now because i was
corrected about something
but
this is not a program where i lie to the
audience or pretend to have beliefs that
i don't either because i think it will
be more interesting or generate more
clicks or views or whatever the case may
be i don't do that there are shows that
do it and i won't name them partially
because i don't watch them uh but but
there are shows i'm sure that do that
but this is not one of them all right
okay joe wrote in joe says hey david i
was scrolling through facebook when i
noticed one of my anti-vaxx facebook
friends who's a nurse
share the below post from halifax health
in florida i can't wrap my head around
why a hospital would share this how do
we fight this nonsense this is food to
anti-vaxx republicans can you look into
it so what joe is referring to is that
halifax health shared something showing
that a lot of the people
in the hospital
um were vaccinated with covet that there
were a bunch of vaccinated people in the
hospital and as i've said before one of
the things we we must understand
is that as more and more people are
vaccinated
the odds by sheer base rates that more
of the hospitalized are vaccinated goes
up what we have to understand is your
relative risk as i said before the
thought experiment is
in a country where you have 100 percent
vaccination
anyone who's hospitalized will be
vaccinated does that mean the vaccines
don't reduce the risk of hospitalization
of course not and as we've seen many
times before you know it i'm i'm making
up numbers here
imagine you have 70 percent vaccination
and
40
of the hospitalized are vaccinated well
that's a much larger share of the
population
and they are relatively a much smaller
portion of the hospitalized and as we've
seen before the risk reduction for
hospitalization or death from cobit is
significant i don't even remember the
latest numbers at this point because we
continue to get
more and more uh precise numbers but you
have to understand the relative risk and
joe is not wrong
it is food or fodder for anti-vax
republicans
because they don't understand the
meaning of the numbers if they
understood math and base rates then it
would not be anti-vaxx fodder
unfortunately they don't and therefore
it is
okay steve wrote to me here's an
interesting perspective from steve or
stephen
trump's vaccine advocacy is an indicator
he doesn't intend to run in 2024. steve
writes david knowing that everything
trump does is to benefit himself why is
he now promoting the vaccine knowing it
will cost him potential voters perhaps
he's more concerned about his legacy
might this be an indicator that he does
not intend to run in 2024
at this point
i have no idea this is one argument that
can be made trump is now going fully for
vaccines because he doesn't care about
the repercussions the problem is he's
not really going fully he's still
talking about you should have your
freedoms and i'm not sure about
vaccinating kids and all these different
things so i reject that he's really
going that much pro-vaccine but the
counterpoint that some people have wrote
to me have written to me and said some
people who wrote to me said
um is that what trump is doing is
getting ahead of the fact that it it
does seem plausible that in the next
year
covid will be dramatically reduced it'll
go into an endemic phase and he wants to
make sure that as that happens people
think of him and the vaccines so
you can pick any interpretation you want
i don't know that we're really going to
know what trump's thinking is at this
point in time
eric wrote
um oh actually eric's making this exact
point by the way this is not the crazy
anti-vaxx eric and mass this is a
different eric and mass he says hey
david do you think trump's recent
endorsement of the vaccine is being
caused by some health officials
forecasting that the coveted pandemic is
hopefully winding down maybe he's
realizing there will be something to
take credit for soon so rather than
belittling it he's better off taking
credit for it thanks
this is exactly what i was just
suggesting that some people were writing
to me about must have been in my head
because
we had this email here
that's another interpretation of trump
now saying the vaccines are good
the vaccines are safe and i made them
um this is just as plausible an
explanation
okay mr h wrote to me
about dr anthony fauci
and says greetings is it possible that
dr fauci may need to seek political
asylum
if the republicans gain full control of
the government regards i
am not willing to accept
that dr fauci would need to leave the
country for safety
if republicans take over in november now
a lot of really bad things are likely to
happen if republicans take over in
november there's no question about that
but particularly because he has
armed security which is insane that dr
fauci needs it but he does
i believe that dr fauci will be able to
safely stay in the united states
even if republicans gain full control of
the government in 2024 or control of the
house and or senate
in 2022 if you have a different
perspective on dr fauci's safety
by all means let me know
olov wrote in about a mathematical error
which i always want to correct
he says david sir in your january 12th
show you claimed one percent and point
five percent were imaginary numbers when
talking about omicron giving fewer
hospitalizations in mathematics
imaginary numbers are well defined it's
real numbers multiplied by an imaginary
unit i
i is defined as if you square it it
equals minus 1. i would rather use made
up numbers instead of imaginary this is
a completely fair critique
i said the other day these are imaginary
numbers and it really was not precise
what i meant was i'm making these
numbers up
imaginary numbers have a precisely
defined
meaning in math
and i apologize
if i confused anybody oh with that
ruth wrote in and ruth says the future
of the united states scares me
ruth says hi david i've been listening
to your show for about a year i really
appreciate your reporting on current
events after listening to yourself and
others i'm very concerned about the
future of the us me too
lately i have been considering moving
out of the u.s i was wondering if you've
ever thought about this yourself or if
you think the us will turn around yeah i
mean listen um i am i i always
have you know we we learn more and more
about kind of people's um
there's this return to the mean thing
where we learn that people seem to have
different levels of kind of natural
optimism satisfaction and happiness and
individual events will push and pull us
one way or the other but that most
people unless they work really hard have
kind of a natural mean or status quo and
my status quo is kind of like cautious
optimism but let's make sure we have a
backup plan in place
so as many of you know i was born in
argentina i could move back to argentina
anytime that's one backup now for the
last many decades
it's not been an appealing thing because
things have been worse in argentina than
in the us in many many different ways so
that's one backup
number two is uh i could move to israel
and obtain citizenship there so that's a
backup and the third backup that i'm
waiting on uh or working on right now is
there i have many of you might know i
have family roots in poland
uh my family from poland
on my maternal grandfather's side
fled poland because of the holocaust
fled to argentina
there is a provision
where if you can prove your lineage and
that your family left under those
circumstances you can get a polish
passport which would give me eu
access full eu access i am working on
that it's really difficult because by
its nature the records
that prove that lineage from poland
are
potentially non-existent because they
were burned up in the holocaust the part
of poland that my family is from
is now part of belarus as many of you
know the political situation in belarus
is complex there are not exactly good
working relationships between belarus
and poland so if anybody here is in
belarus and might be able to help me get
the documents i need get in touch but
that's my third backup that i'm working
on and i have not
uh seriously considered permanently
leaving the us but certainly i am
worried enough about the future of the
us
that i want to have a plan in place so
that's a long answer ruth but i hope
i've answered it
to your satisfaction
email info davidpakman.com if you have
anything that you want to see in the
mailbag we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
use the coupon code wow22 to get a
discount and we'll see you either on the
bonus show today or back on the monday
program